solo tenemos 17 millones de habitantes,
y tendremos un déficit de 125 000 enfermeros en los años venideros.
¿Pero cómo terminamos con esta idea
de juntar a toda la gente con todo tipo de enfermedades
en un edificio gigantesco?
Tenemos que ir al pasado, a los antiguos griegos.
En el 400 a. C. se erigieron templos de sanación
donde la gente iba para recibir un diagnóstico,
tratamiento y sanación.
Luego, unos 2000 años
existieron centros religiosos de cuidados
hasta la era de la revolución industrial,
donde comienzan a crearse hospitales como líneas de ensamblaje
basados en los principios de la revolución industrial
para producir eficientemente
y hacer que los productos, en este caso los pacientes,
salgan del hospital lo más pronto posible.
Durante el siglo pasado, hemos visto muchas innovaciones interesantes.
Descubrimos cómo crear insulina.
Inventamos el marcapaso y los rayos X
y llegamos a esta nueva era maravillosa de vender terapias genéticas.
Pero el gran desafío de mejorar nuestro sistema hospitalario
aún está ante nosotros.
Creo que ahora es el momento porque tenemos la oportunidad
de revolucionar todo nuestro sistema
y olvidar nuestro actual sistema hospitalario.
Creo que es hora de crear un nuevo sistema
que gire en torno al cuidado de la salud en casa.
Estudios recientes muestran
que el 46 % del cuidado hospitalario
puede trasladarse al hogar del paciente.
Eso es mucho.
Es principalmente para los pacientes que sufren de enfermedades crónicas.
De esta manera, los hospitales pueden y deberían
reducirse a centros de cuidados móviles más pequeños y ágiles
enfocándose en el cuidado de casos más graves.
La neonatología, el cuidado intensivo, las cirugías y los escaneos
continuarían realizándose en los hospitales.
Por lo menos, así lo creo, en un futuro cercano.
Hace un par de semanas, hablé con una colega
a cuya madre le habían diagnosticado un cáncer incurable,
y ella me dijo: "Niels, es duro.
Es duro saber que solo le quedan pocos meses de vida.
En vez de jugar con sus nietos,
ella tiene que trasladarse tres veces a la semanas,
en un viaje dos horas de ida y vuelta a Amsterdam
para recibir su tratamiento y hacerse sus exámenes".
Eso me rompe el corazón
porque sabemos que una enfermera profesional
puede tomarle muestras de sangre en casa, ¿cierto?
Y si ella pudiese hacerse sus exámenes y recibir su tratamiento en casa,
podría entonces hacer las cosas que son realmente importantes para ella
en sus últimos meses.
Mi propia madre, que tiene 82 años... que Dios la bendiga...
evita ir al hospital
porque se le hace difícil planificar y administrar el viaje.
Así que mi hermana y yo la ayudamos.
Pero hay mucha gente mayor que evita el tratamiento
y dejan pasar mucho tiempo, asumiendo un riesgo para sus vidas,
y terminan en costosos cuidados intensivos.
El Dr. Covinsky, un investigador clínico de la Universidad de California
concluyó que un tercio de los pacientes sobre los 70
y más de la mitad de los pacientes sobre los 85
salen del hospital más discapacitados que cuando entraron.
Y un problema práctico
que muchos pacientes se enfrentan cuando tienen que ir al hospital es:
¿A dónde voy con mi principal compañero de vida;
a dónde voy con mi perro?
Ese es nuestro perro, linda, ¿cierto?
(Risas)
Pero no es solo por la conveniencia.
Son las hospitalizaciones innecesarias y los costos.
Art, un amigo mío,
tuvo que quedar hospitalizado por una cirugía menor
y estuvo en el hospital más de dos semanas
porque necesitaba un tipo específico de antibióticos intravenosos.
Ocupó una cama dos semanas
que le costó más de mil euros diarios.
Es ridículo.
Estos costos son realmente la causa del problema.
Hemos visto que en muchas de nuestras economías globales
el costo del cuidado sanitario ha aumentado como un porcentaje del PIB
en los últimos años.
Aquí vemos que en los últimos 50 años
el costo de los cuidados sanitarios en Alemania ha aumentado del 5 %
a cerca del 11 % hoy en día.
En EE. UU. lo hemos visto aumentar de un 6 % a más de un 17 %.
Una gran porción de estos costos es producto de las inversiones
en hospitales grandes y lujosos.
Estos edificios no son flexibles
y mantienen un sistema donde las camas deben estar ocupadas
para ser eficientes.
No hay incentivo para que un hospital funcione con menos camas.
Solo pensar en eso los enferma, ¿cierto?
He aquí una realidad: el costo del tratamiento de mi amigo Art en casa
podría llegar a ser 10 veces más económico que en el hospital.
Y allí es donde llegaremos.
La cama de hospital del futuro estará en nuestros hogares.
Ya está comenzando.
El cuidado en casa a nivel global aumenta un 10 % año hace ya más de año.
A partir de mi propia experiencia, veo que la logística y la tecnología
permiten que las soluciones de cuidados médicos en casa funcionen.
La tecnología ya nos permite hacer cosas
que anteriormente ocurrían exclusivamente en los hospitales.
Exámenes de diagnóstico, como pruebas de sangre,
glucosa y orina pueden hacerse en la comodidad del hogar.
Cada vez hay más aparatos conectados,
como los marcapasos y las bombas de insulinas,
que pueden enviar una señal si se requiere de ayuda inmediata.
Y toda esa tecnología
permite recolectar más datos sobre la salud del paciente,
y toda esa información conlleva a un mejor control
y a menos errores médicos...
recuerden, la tercera causa de muerte
en EE. UU.
Lo veo a diario en el trabajo.
Trabajo en logística
y para mí, el cuidado de la salud en casa funciona.
Así vemos que un repartidor entrega la medicina
a la casa del paciente.
Una enfermera lo acompaña y administra la droga
en la casa del paciente.
Es así de sencillo.
¿Se acuerdan de mi amigo Art?
Ahora puede recibir sus antibióticos intravenosos en la comodidad de su hogar,
sin pijamas de hospital ni la pésima comida del hospital,
ni el riesgo a las superbacterias resistentes a los antibióticos,
a las que solo puede exponerse en los hospitales.
Y hay más.
Ahora la gente mayor puede recibir el tratamiento que necesita
en la comodidad de sus hogares
junto a sus compañeros de vida.
Y no hay necesidad de manejar horas y horas
solo para los exámenes y recibir tratamiento.
En los Países Bajos y en Dinamarca
hemos visto muy buenos resultados en las clínicas del cáncer
donde se administran quimioterapias en los hogares de los pacientes,
e incluso a veces con varios pacientes juntos.
Lo mejor para estos pacientes
ha sido la reducción del estrés,
la ansiedad y la depresión.
El cuidado en casa también les ayuda a recuperar un sentido de normalidad
y libertad en sus vidas,
tanto así que les está ayudando a olvidarse de su enfermedad.
Pero Niels, es cuidado médico en casa...
¿qué pasaría si no tengo un hogar,
o sí tengo uno pero no tengo a nadie que me cuide
o que me ayude a abrir la puerta?
Bueno, aquí entra nuestra economía compartida,
o como me gusta llamarlo, el Airbnb del cuidado en casa.
En los Países Bajos, las iglesias y las organizaciones de cuidado
emparejan a la gente que necesita cuidados y compañía
con la gente que tiene un hogar
y puede proveerles de cuidado y compañía.
El cuidado en casa es más económico,
es más fácil de administrar y se puede organizar rápidamente...
en esas zonas rurales que mencionamos, así como en situaciones de crisis humanitaria
donde es más seguro, rápido y económico organizar las cosas en casa.
El cuidado sanitario en casa puede aplicarse en zonas acomodadas
pero también en comunidades de bajos recursos.
El cuidado sanitario en casa funciona en países desarrollados
y en países en desarrollo.
Me apasiona ayudar a mejorar las vidas de los pacientes
gracias al cuidado de la salud en casa.
Me apasiona ayudar a facilitar
a la gente mayor a que obtenga el tratamiento que necesitan
en la comodidad de sus hogares,
junto con sus mejores compañeros de vida.
Me apasiona contribuir al cambio
y ayudar a que sean los pacientes y no las enfermedades
los que lleven el control de sus vidas.
Para mí, ese es el cuidado de la salud administrado en el hogar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)